hello again and thank you for joining us
for day one of the health and life
sciences track of the microsoft research
summit focusing on discovery
we've explored so many important topics
and accelerating innovation in health
and life sciences this is just a glimpse
into what is to come for future sessions
focused on health and life sciences and
for tomorrow's track where we'll focus
on delivery
here we'll explore the role of research
and innovation in dismantling the
barriers in to health equity
increasing access to health care
strengthening resilience and
transforming the delivery of healthcare
across geographies through new category
defining technologies and experiences
reflecting on today it is critical now
more than ever we as scientists
researchers technologists and business
leaders come together to collaborate
across sectors and geographies
across disciplines and expertise
to innovate share learnings and explore
new ways of advancing the human
condition
empowering the highest levels of human
knowledge to push the limits of biology
and ai will advance medicine increase
equity in health care and support a
healthy global community
thank you for joining us we look forward
to more engaging sessions tomorrow